bon monsieur rebsamen a été réélu et en
tant que républicain je tiens à le
féliciter
je suis fier d'eux du combat que j'ai
mené souvenez-vous il ya quelques mois
mon adversaire disait que j'étais un
maire rural l'élu de gouttière disais
que je n'étais pas connu et bien je suis
connue et j'ai fait oeuvre de
rassemblement d'union une droite
unie qui s'est battue qui s'est bien
battue et je pense que l'échec de
monsieur rebsamen c'est d'avoir mis le
front national au conseil municipal de
dijon et tout ça par un tripatouillage
électoral souvenez-vous le gouvernement
à changer la loi électorale en abaissant
à 10% des votants le nombre pour être le
pourcentage pour être au 2e tour alors
qu'avant c'était sur les inscrits c'est
totalement différent et je pense que si
nous avions eu un combat à 2 en soirée
deux semaines et moi je pense que ça
aurait été différent mais c'est bien
monsieur françois rebsamen vous c'est
pas votre propre échec parce que quand
même là
la droite fait un score historiquement
bas sur sur dijon et finalement on peut
penser aussi que c'est là que le fn en
profite l'échec c'est aussi l'abstention
41% de qui se sont abstenus 41% qui ne
sont pas allées sont pas allés voter ils
ne sont pas allés voter pour françois
rebsamen qui ne sont pas allés voter
pour les candidats de droite c'est un
échec je pense que c'est un échec aussi
pour dijon parce que quand le front
national rendre dans une ville ça prouve
que la misère s'installe que le chômage
s'installe et c'est un échec en france
on aime ça